bonsoir et bienvenue à tous voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce mercredi
un tgv a percuté un camion sur un
passage à niveau ce matin dans l'ain la
collision a fait un mort le chauffeur du
poids lourd a une trentaine de blessés
dans la rame une affaire embarrassante
pour christine boutin en pleine
polémique sur le logement le canard
enchaîné révèle que son directeur de
cabinet occupe un vaste appartement
public à bas prix au coeur de paris à
l'étranger l'espoir pour ingrid
betancourt après l'annonce des farc pour
accélérer un échange d'otages françois
fillon se dit prêt à accueillir sur le
sol français des guérilleros sont
indésirables en colombie polémique en
europe sur les gaz à effet de serre la
commission de bruxelles veut taxer les
constructeurs automobiles trop polluants
dès 2012 l'allemagne furieuse dénoncent
une injustice
enfin nous évoquerons la plainte de ce
client du fournisseur d'accès orange
mohamed zaïdi s'est vu attribuer un mot
de passe raciste sale arabe
l'entreprise a fait des excuses et
cherche à savoir qui est responsable
tgv contre poids lourds c'est donc un
accident rarissime pour un train à
grande vitesse qui s'est produit ce
matin près de bourg en bresse
apparemment le camion n'aurait jamais dû
emprunter cette route le chauffeur est
mort sur le coup
sur place dans l'ain virginie pichet
philippe fidh c'était un convoi
exceptionnel transportant un énorme
concasseur de gravats sous la violence
du choc
il s'est littéralement disloquée vers
9h15 ce matin le tgv vient de quitter
bourg-en-bresse en direction de genève
lorsque la collision se produit que le
drakkar
j'ai savent tout volé en l'air new age
de coûts mais voilà
à bord du tgv les 190 passagers vivent
quelques secondes de chaos
et pourtant déplacé l'êta fondée
décoller complètement
les gens sont été éjecté mer vers
l'avant évidemment ce camion un peu
partout des étangs ses 60 et de gaz
les gens couraient un peu saoulé voit
donc on a eu très peur trente sept
personnes ont été légèrement blessées
dont le conducteur le chauffeur du poids
lourd lui est décédé un bilan mesure est
toutefois car le tgv n'a pas déraillé
l'impact fait qu'il ya eu distorsion des
rails est donc là l'avant du train est
sorti des rails le train est resté droit
en position droite n'y a pas eu de
couchage suivre sur le flanc parce que
heureusement parce que cela aurait
engendré des blessés en nombre plus
important sur cette voie qui n'est pas
réservé aux tgv la vitesse du train
n'excédait pas 160 km heure au moment de
l'accident
le camion était immobilisée au milieu du
passage à niveau il semble avoir
rencontré des difficultés à franchir les
portiques de sécurité qui protègent les
caténaires
il semble que le camion empruntait un
itinéraire qui ne devait pas prendre
il ne devait pas se trouver à cet
endroit d'abord parce que compte tenu du
gabarit du camion il pourrait pas passer
sous les portiques
reste à savoir pourquoi le convoi à
modifier sa feuille de route passant
outre les règles strictes qui régissent
ce type de transport on le disait ce
type d'accident est rare pour un tgv
mais plusieurs collisions à des passages
à niveau se sont produites coup sur coup
ces dernières semaines pierre monnet
gier il y a deux ans dans le nord c'est
un camion transportant des bouteilles de
gaz qui explose percuté par un train par
miracle il n'y a pas de victime mais les
passages à niveaux restent dangereux
en 2006 ils ont été le lieu de 140
collision tuant 40 personnes depuis une
dizaine d'années les passages à niveau
les plus dangereux sont peu à peu
supprimés réseau ferré de france
souhaite supprimer les passages à niveau
présente des dangers particuliers soit
parce que 5,3 des voix ou énormément de
voiture soit parce que la configuration
du dieu fait qu'on a une obésité des
choses comme ça ils refusent avons un
programme de suppression des passages à
niveau et nous en supprimerons au moins
une vingtaine chaque à nice
il reste aujourd'hui dix-neuf mille
passages à niveau en france dont 360
sont jugés préoccupants des aménagements
ponctuels sont réalisés comme
l'installation de radars aux abords des
croisements construire un pont creuser
un tunnel pour les véhicules reste la
solution la plus sûre mais elle a un
coût 5 millions d'euros pour chaque
passage à niveau supprimer la question
des sans logis on l'a appris en fin
d'après midi un homme de 62 ans a été
trouvé mort hier dans sa voiture à
l'intérieur d'un box pour automobiles
avant près de paris il vivait là depuis
quelques semaines suite à une rupture
conjugale et avait refusé des
propositions d'hébergement en hôtel
il souffrait de diabète et de problèmes
cardiaques rien n'indique qu'il soit
mort de froid hier le samu social de
paris a révélé les résultats d'une
enquête qui permettent de se faire une
idée sur le profil des sans abri huit
sur dix sont des hommes un sur cinq est
sans papiers edouard baer jean sylvain
de gras à 54 ans francis vie dans sa
baraque comme il l'appelle dans le bois
de vincennes un abri de fortune
construits avec du bois de récupération
et des bâches plastiques
j'ai l'épaule j'ai tout ce que je veux
comme lui quatre sans domicile fixe sur
cinq sont des hommes même si les femmes
sont toujours plus nombreuses la
population des sans abri vieilli donc
plus vulnérables l'âge moyen des sdf est
passé de 35 ans en 1999 à 40 aujourd'hui
un quart à plus de 50 ans et cette part
augmente sérieusement côté nationalité
la population s'est internationalisé les
sans abri sont français pour moitié 33%
sont africains 11 % viennent d'europe et
sur le total 1 sur 5 est sans papiers
ces chiffres sur le profil des sans abri
ont été révélés par le samu social
auteur d'une enquête menée sur sept ans
auprès de 60000 sdr
population a beaucoup évolué elle est
très hétérogène les besoins des patients
sont très différents il ya des gens qui
ont débattu qui ont des besoins d'une
prise en charge médicale notamment en
question psychiatrique
et puis après il ya des personnes qui
ont besoin de deux types d'hébergement
particulier pas forcément collectif la
moitié des sdf se déclarent sans
ressources
ce qui les a poussés à la rue
l'expulsion de leur logement pour 30% le
départ du pays d'origine pour 25
viennent ensuite les conflits familiaux
la maladie ou la prison est en pleine
polémique sur le logement le canard
enchaîné révèle je vous le disais une
affaire embarrassante pour la ministre
christine boutin son directeur de
cabinet bénéficie d'un appartement
public au coeur de paris à des
conditions très avantageuses france gêne
au zoo sylvain doba dans un immeuble
haussmannien des beaux quartiers de
paris
appartement de 190 mètres carrés bien
exposé avec vue imprenable sur la
chapelle du val-de-grâce loyer 1200
euros par mois c'est quatre fois moins
que le prix du marché leurs locataires
jean paul bolufer le directeur de
cabinet du ministre du logement
christine boutin bien obligé cet après
midi à l'assemblée de reconnaître que
cette situation pose problème et carrés
au coeur ce qui concerne mon directeur
de cabinet
on va permettrait de régler le problème
entre lui et moi je vous remercie
c'est le canard enchaîné qui révèle
l'information jean paul bolufer est en
fait le bras droit de la ministre son
appartement qu'il loue depuis les années
80 à la régie immobilière de la ville de
paris n'est pas un hlm mais il est censé
être réservé aux classes moyennes
cette situation n'est pas illégal mais
elle est quelque peu embarrassante pour
un homme qui jusqu'ici n'avait pas de
mots assez durs pour dénoncer les abus
en matière de la chaîne aujourd'hui se
trouve pour parler très vite dans le
parc hlm des gens qui ne devraient pas y
être
je considère que c'est un véritable
scandale et nous sommes en train de
préparer un texte pour mettre en place
de véritables surloyer pour ceux qui
occupent indûment le parc hlm mini loyer
pour un maxi appart le constat indigne
les associations de défense des
mal-logés 190 m j'avais des familles
avec beaucoup d'enfants qui vivent dans
des hôtels où ils consomment seulement
imaginaire et qui seraient logés tout à
fait convenablement dans au sein du
gouvernement martin hirsch haut
commissaire aux solidarités actives
estime que jean paul bolufer devrait
proposer sa démission
la régie immobilière de la ville de
paris quant à elle a décidé de résilier
son bail
on en vient à ce regain d'espoir pour
ingrid betancourt après l'annoncé hier
des farc d'une possible libération de
trois otages avec d'abord cette toute
dernière minute la libération des trois
otages seraient en cours
c'est ce qu'affirme donc à l'instant
l'ex mari d'ingrid betancourt fabrice de
loi ils citent des informations d'un
émissaire et d'après lui les trois
otages devraient arriver très vite au
venezuela on n'a pas plus de précisions
pour l'instant
et nous y reviendrons bien sûr dès que
possible tout à l'heure vous avez aperçu
les images d'une manifestation de
soutien à la franco colombienne était
organisée au trocadéro à paris
et puis françois fillon s'est dit prêt
pour accélérer un éventuel échange à
accueillir des guérilleros des farc
indésirable dans leur pays sur le sol
français on écoute maintenant la
réaction de la mère d'ingrid betancourt
qui elle aussi participé à un défilé en
colombie réaction donc à cette
éventuelle libération
déclara les bébés y conduit j'espère que
pour l'année prochaine est serré avec
une église avec mélanie le réseau et et
toute la famille astiz et moir l'espèce
afin d'acheter au sénat elle s'est
traduite dès midi on le disait dès hier
à parmi les trois otages qui pourraient
être libérés il ya l'assistante d'ingrid
betancourt clara roja son histoire est
d'autant plus extraordinaire qu'elle
avait souhaité rester à ses côtés au
côté d'ingrid betancourt alors qu'elle
aurait pu partir au moment de
l'enlèvement
et aussi qu'elle a eu un enfant avec un
guérillero pendant sa captivité
karine comazzi mathias seconde c'était
après un an et demi de captivité
clara rojas avait la force de faire de
l'humour je suis dans la jungle
colombienne dans un endroit paradisiaque
depuis cette dernière preuve de vie la
mère de clara rojas ne faisait que prix
espéré hier soir une longue attente a
pris 20
j'attends ce moment depuis tellement
longtemps depuis vraiment longtemps
et à chaque fois que je parlais de la
libération de ma fille avec goût
j'essayais d'imaginer comment serait ce
moment là clara la jeune avocate doué a
trouvé sa vocation politique aux côtés
d'ingrid betancourt en 91
en 2001 elle abandonne son métier pour
devenir la directrice de campagne et la
colistière de la candidate écologiste
jusqu'à ce jour de février 2002 ou sur
cette route du sud de la colombie les
femmes tombent aux mains des farc
les guerriers roos nous propose de
partir clara roja se refuse elle veut
rester avec ingrid commencent alors cinq
longues années de détention dans la
jungle
en 2004 20 être un plissé manuel son
père est un guérillero enfant de l'amour
ou de la guerre la mère de clara
l'ignorent le jour où nous l'avons
rencontré à bogota elle se rendait chez
la mère d'ingrid
les deux femmes sont devenues compagne
d'infortuné comme leur fille et c'est
ensemble qu'elles sont après la
naissance de l'enfant
depuis que j'ai appris son existence
je veux le tenir dans mes bras grâce à
cet enfant et s'est occupée elle avait
quelqu'un kg né de l'amour et la route
sud l'amour et la tendresse d'un bébé
quelque part dans cette jungle
clara rojas son fils une sénatrice
marche vers une libération promise pas
encore acquise
et je vous le disais il ya un instant
les choses semble-t-il s'accélère
puisque cette libération serait en cours
ce sont les informations que vous
possédez fabrice de loi nous sommes en
ligne en direct avec vous je rappelle
que vous êtes l'ex mari d'ingrid
betancourt d'où tenez-vous ces
informations et quelles sont-elles
précisément alors ces informations me
vielle de l'un des émissaires qui
approche la guerre dans les farc et qui
m'a indiqué que d'une part
l'authenticité du communiqué des farc et
deuxièmement elles viennent du président
chavez lui-même qui a précisé depuis
montevideo puis c'est vrai que les
otages avaient quitté le périmètre de
sécurité ce qu'on appelle les anneaux de
sécurité autour des facs et qu'ils
étaient en route alors vers quelles
destinations ne sont pas toujours mais
nous espérons qu'ils vont pouvoir
apparaître très rapidement probablement
du côté du venezuela
elle serait toujours à l'heure qu'il est
aux mains des farc sous le contrôle des
farc ou déjà dans une zone tampon
nous n'avons absolument aucune précision
à ce niveau là simplement le message et
elle sait qu'elles sont en route
le message autrement dit c'est que cette
libération est une affaire sérieuse
aucune idée non plus du moment où elle
pourrait arriver au venezuela si c'est
bien le venezuela c'est bien lors des
teen sûr nous ne savons pas ça dépend et
ça dépend exclusivement s'il voulait de
la guerre et de ce qui se passe en
colombie donc nous pouvons et nous
espérons que ce sera le plus rapidement
possible et que surtout qu'il qu'elle
puisse parcourir ce chemin en paix merci
fabrice de loi donc pour ces toutes
dernières précisions et bien sûr nous y
revenons d'ici la fin de ce journal si
nous avons d'autres précisions
retour en france avec les ducs s
on est ce qu'on pourrait appeler la der
des ders les cours ont repris à
l'université paris iii censier après
plus d'un mois de blocage
en raison du mouvement de contestation
de la loi pécresse c'est le tout dernier
établissement qui était encore perturbé
ont évoqué récemment la réforme de la
première année de licence pour faire
face à l'échec ou aux problèmes
d'orientation
il faut savoir que de plus en plus
d'étudiants choisissent les filières
courtes et notamment les iut reportage
aurélia bros claire marie denis l'iut de
ville d'avray
ces étudiants sont arrivés ici le bac en
poche pour suivre une formation en deux
ans les instituts universitaires de
technologie sont en plein développement
et séduisent 9 % des bacheliers et
s'ouvre désormais au secteur tertiaire
des travaux pratiques de petites classes
des enseignants proches de leurs élèves
pour s'insérer dans le monde du travail
c'est la bonne équation en ut en effet
le cours paraît que la fac le pour le td
et en plus on a les tp pour voir en fait
concrètement ce qui se passe et
réputation aussi parce que ton de ma
conseillé de faire une minute et mes
professeurs de
toc la fac les 8 et propose désormais
une année d'études supplémentaires en
licence professionnelle une des
formations les plus payantes en matière
d'emploi cette année même je crois dans
beaucoup de nos licences
professionnelles les étudiants étaient
embauchés avant d'avoir terminé le
cursus et on a dû en retenir certains
pour les obliger à terminer leur cursus
pour qu'ils aient leur diplôme avant
d'aller travailler
la formule inspirent les universités
celle de marne-la-vallée compte une
cinquantaine de licences pro et beaucoup
d'enseignants sont issus du monde du
travail
une façon de créer des réseaux ce
jour-là employeurs et jeunes diplômés de
facs parisiennes se rencontraient
surprise des secteurs réputés sinistrés
comme les lettres ou la sociologie
séduisent les entreprises quand janot
est entrée en fac de philo il ya cinq
ans il n'imaginait pas être recruté par
cet homme associé d'un grand cabinet
d'audit
je pensais pas vraiment là les
professionnels époque non non non je ne
pensais pas vraiment jeu j'ai en fait
j'ai continué la la philosophie en fait
par goût par groupe en la matière la
technique fait financier à la technique
comptable ça ça prend ça c'est pas le
souci c'est cet étudiant a appris à
prendre cet étudiant a appris à rédiger
c'était ayant appris à être autonome cet
étudiant a pris à s'affirmer
c'est ça qui nous intéresse et qui te
courtes ou longues
ils sont encore nombreux à privilégier
l'université mais désormais bts iut
attire 30 % des nouveaux étudiants
c'est une position très attendu que
vient de faire connaître la commission
européenne sur les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et elle provoque déjà la
polémique bruxelles veut taxer les
constructeurs automobiles trop polluants
dès 2012
c'est une petite révolution qui
s'annonce pour ces constructeurs
l'allemagne furieuse dénoncent déjà une
injustice françois beaudonnet damien
louvet
elles sont toutes de la même marque mais
chez ce concessionnaire auto on trouve
en fait deux types de voitures ce
véhicule-là émet 119 grammes d'émissions
de co2 en revanche ce véhicule-là émet
de 186 grammes d'émissions co2 autant
dire que pour le premier modèle le moins
polluant le constructeur n'a pas de
souci à se faire mais pour ce gros 4 4
il va devoir faire des efforts
la commission européenne entend des
faits faire baisser les émissions
moyennes de dioxyde de carbone de 160
grammes par kilomètre aujourd'hui à 120
grammes dans cinq ans les acheteurs de
voitures en europe vont pouvoir dépenser
beaucoup moins en essence ils vont
économiser des milliards d'euros
c'est donc bon pour l'environnement est
bon pour le consommateur mais avant de
faire des économies
l'automobiliste européen devra d'abord
payer plus cher ses voitures moins
gourmandes et plus sophistiquées + 6 % à
l'achat soit environ 1300 euros en plus
par véhicule neuf
outre-rhin la nouvelle réglementation
européenne fait grincer des dents les
constructeurs allemand spécialiste des
grosses cylindrées produisent des
véhicules plus polluants 173 g en
moyenne contre 144 pour les
constructeurs français et italiens
sous prétexte de protection de
l'environnement nous allons assister à
une guerre concurrentielle entre les
industriels de l'automobile en europe
les nouvelles règles seront assortis de
pénalités financières pour les
constructeurs qui ne respecteraient pas
les normes de pollution
le transport routier en europe
représente à lui seul un cinquième des
émissions de dioxyde de carbone
bonsoir jérôme baugnies vous êtes en
direct à berlin les allemands sont
effectivement furieux là bas c'est une
affaire nationale tout à fait david
grosse colère ici en allemagne à la fois
le gouvernement et les constructeurs
automobiles font bloc contre ces
propositions de bruxelles
c'est une politique qui porte préjudice
à l'allemagne s'insurge de la
chancelière angela merkel qui pourtant
nous habituer à plus de diplomatie dans
ses déclarations européennes
seulement voilà l'industrie automobile
c'est le fer de lance du champion du
monde des exportations et pour la
chancelière protéger cette injustice
c'est la priorité des priorités car elle
implique beaucoup d'emplois seulement
par cette querelle
aussi de ternir l'image écologique de
son pays qu'elle a lancée dans une
politique résolue de réduction des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de 40%
d'ici à 2020 notamment par les énergies
renouvelables
seulement voilà dans l'état actuel des
choses l'allemagne est l'un des plus
gros pollueurs de la planète avec les
centrales électriques au charbon
et bien sûr les voitures à grosses
cylindrées vous avez ici en allemagne a
pas de limitation générale de vitesse
sur les autoroutes et les allemands
revendique comme un droit d'appuyer sur
le champignon
évidemment sa folio merci jérôme pour
ces précisions est à noter que si les
constructeurs jugent ces mesures trop
drastiques et bien les associations
écologistes
elles les jugent très insuffisante un
mot puisque nous étions et jérôme bonnet
en direct sur la parution de ce livre
de notre correspondant l'allemagne grand
reporter pour découvrir les coulisses de
l'actualité aux éditions michalon
l'actualité sociale en france trois
heures de discussion pour une année de
réformes la conférence qui réunit c'est
nicolas sarkozy et l'ensemble des
syndicats s'est achevée en fin d'après
midi près de l'elysée objectif établir
un calendrier de l'assurance chômage au
contrat de travail une demi douzaine de
sujets sont lancés en même temps a la
sortie certains syndicats ont mises en
garde d'ailleurs contre impossible
embouteillages il évoque l'impatience du
politique
laurence parisot pour le medef parle
elle d'un bon état d'esprit
à noter par ailleurs que ceux qui ne
payent pas la redevance auront un répit
en 2008 nicolas sarkozy a demandé que
l'exonération soit maintenu une année
supplémentaire pour les quelques 750
mille personnes âgées à faible revenu
qui sont concernés et toujours à propos
de social à cette action en justice
d'une quinzaine d'hôtesses de l'air et
de stewards d'une filiale d'air france
pour faire des économies cette société
cityjet installées en irlande demande à
ses salariés de s'installer à londres ou
à dublin où les cotisations sociales
sont beaucoup plus faibles
c'est aussi un visage de la
mondialisation jean-paul chapelle jean
francois monier
cette compagnie fait la navette entre
paris et la city de londres
la destination préférée des banquiers
d'affaires
une filiale du groupe air france met une
compagnie de droit irlandais la société
a décidé début novembre que les hôtesses
et stewards serait basé en irlande
j'ai là personnel la chargée du
personnel navigant commercial à paris
qui m'a appelé avant la réunion
d'information pour m'informer que les
rumeurs étaient fondées et en me disant
que je devais déménager soit dublin soit
à londres soit donné ma démission
c'est simplement et pour ceux qui ne
déménage pas une perspective allait
prendre leur service à dublin pas faire
douze heures de travail dans une journée
quand on a déjà trouvé y est enfin oui
j'ai trois heures avons peur de
témoigner à visage découvert car depuis
trois ans ces salariés travaillent en
france avec un contrat irlandais un
salaire 30% plus élevés caer france mais
plus de précarité et des cotisations
sociales irlandaise très réduite
la série d'ultra libéralisme anglo-saxon
c'est à dire que les salariés
on était embauchés sous un régime
irlandais avec l'application de loi
irlandaise devant l'intention des
salariés de porter l'affairé aux
prud'hommes
la direction affiche aujourd'hui une
volonté de conciliation et les
personnels navigants des étiquettes qui
sont actuellement en france et qui
veulent y rester peuvent bien et d'y
rester sous régime français avec les
cotisations france elle donc il frappe
c'est pas un sujet promis ceux qui
veulent rester en france devront donc
signer bientôt un nouveau contrat
français cette fois
économie encore la flambée des prix
agricoles fait aussi des heureux
alors que le revenu moyen des
exploitants est en hausse de 12% le
revenu des céréaliers français lui a
doublé en moyenne l'an passé c'est ce
qu'indique le ministère de l'agriculture
chantal kimmerlin julien voix si le
thermomètre est descendu très bas dans
le vexin ce matin le moral de philippe
durand lui est plutôt à la hausse
le blick qui glissent entre ses mains
c'est presque de l'or
en tout cas c'est exceptionnel depuis un
an il s'est produit ce qui se produit
peut-être une fois par siècle qu'on
pressentait mais on savait finalement
pas quand c'est que les cours
augmentaient de quasiment 100% partie de
100 euros la tonne il y a un an le
dernier stock de céréales de philippe
durand se vend aujourd'hui 230 euros la
tonne grâce à la demande mondiale une
hausse du chiffre d'affaires qui peut
faire rêver et qui l'aidera à relancer
son exploitation de 260 ha bah j'ai un
chiffre d'affaires si vous voulez qui va
augmenter à peu près deux ans va dire
30%
je vais investir je pense que je vais
investir et je vais essayer de comédiens
de rembourser peut-être un peu un peu
d'emprunts parce que
mal y en a aussi et il y un bémol les
frais généraux sont augmentés les
engrais + 70% le fioul les produits
sanitaires mais là dans l'autre pour
philippe durant les fêtes de noël
s'annonce plutôt crise joyeuse que
l'année dernière à plus de cadeaux
peut-être pas mais enfin noël sera un
petit peu plus joli certainement la
consommation mondiale ne cessant
d'augmenter les cours de produits
agricoles continueront à la hausse
bonne nouvelle pour philippe n'est
peut-être moins bonne pour les
consommateurs
à l'étranger certains n'y croyaient plus
la belgique a finalement pu se doter
d'un gouvernement un gouvernement
intérimaire et ce après six mois
d'impasse politique un accord a été
trouvé entre trois partis francophones
et de flamands et les divergences
restent entières et ce gouvernement ne
doit pas durer
théoriquement plus deux trois mois vous
vous souvenez sans doute de cette tuerie
si l'été dernier à duisbourg en
allemagne six membres de la mafia
italienne avait été assassiné et bien
plusieurs arrestations ont eu lieu ces
derniers jours dans le cadre de l'
enquête
quatre mois après nous avons souhaité
revenir sur le travail
les unités spéciales de la police
italienne contre la mafia
nos correspondants et l'ibis arias et
karen guillaumin ont pu accompagner les
enquêteurs spécialisés
voici le reportage 6 heures du matin au
commissariat central de palerme dernier
briefing pour les hommes de la catho
randy l'unité d'élite de la police
sicilienne vous ne verrez pas leur
visage
ces policiers la préfère l'anonymat
l'objectif ce jour-là perquisitionné un
appartement à la recherche d'une cache
d'armes
il faut faire vite se sachant traquer
les mafieux font disparaître toutes les
preuves de leurs activités une fois sur
place les chiens vont permettre de
découvrir la tâche en question sous une
plaque de marbre
mais les armes ne sont plus là ces
dernières années ces policiers comptent
plus de succès que des chèques en avril
2006 il arrête bernardo provenzano le
chef de cosa nostra caché à corleone
il ya un mois c'est au tour de salvatore
lo piccolo successeur de provins nano
interpellé après 23 ans de clandestinité
des enquêtes de longue haleine qui
démarre dans ce bureau par des centaines
d'heures d'écouté
le plus dur c'est de déchiffrer ce
qu'ils disent au téléphone à demi mot on
doit être capable de comprendre où se
tiendra leur prochain rendez vous qui
sont les personnes qu'ils rencontrent
moi je les écoute depuis des années je
connais le sont leurs voix je décrypte
leur état d'esprit
c'est comme si je vivais par me fait mal
lors ces policiers sont passés maîtres
dans l'art de décoder des messages
apparemment anodin que s'échangent les
mafieux en cavale
là par exemple l'un d'entre eux écrit à
son chef est muni je t'assure que tu es
toujours présent dans mes pensées
et il met trois points d'exclamation qui
est en train d'accomplir la mission que
ce dernier les policiers de palerme
traque également les petits mafieux de
quartier ce qui rackettent les
commerçants sur cette vidéo un flagrant
délit un entrepreneur remet 2000 euros
en liquide un membre de la mafia
ce dernier croit s'éloigner
tranquillement mais la police
l'attendait et l'interpellent un peu
plus loin avant d'en arriver là il faut
des journées de surveillance brandt
cacho quartier populaire de palerme fief
de la mafia 2 policiers suivent une
voiture grise
ils doivent recueillir un maximum
d'informations sur l'homme qui l'a
conduit soupçonné de contrôler le racket
dans le quartier on apprécie un émetteur
satellite sur sa voiture qui nous
signalent tous ses déplacements
ce quartier a toujours été très
difficile pour nous la mafia est partout
ici nous risquons d'être repérés regarde
il repart il repart allons-y et la
filature reprend les policiers de
palerme ne veulent pas desserré leur
étreinte
ils savent que la mafia est affaibli
mais qu'elle n'est pas encore à l'agonie
en france une manifestation nationale
des avocats a partout comme ici à
poitiers en grève des audiences ils ont
pratiqué les consultations gratuites et
ce pour protester contre le projet de
réforme du divorce qui n'impose plus
vous le savez la présence d'un juge et
donc d'un avocat dans certains cas mais
seulement celle d'un notaire il s'agit
d'un projet de réforme pour l'instant on
en vient à cette affaire étonnante et
disons le consternante
clients du fournisseur d'accès orange
mohamed zaïdi s'est vu attribuer un mot
de passe raciste sale arabe en un seul
mot il a bien sûr porté plainte
l'entreprise a fait des excuses elle
cherche maintenant à savoir qui est
responsable
francis mazier philippe dumas y paye à
marquer ce sale arabe a elle eu à air à
bfm croyable ce français d'origine
marocaine veut des explications sur son
nouveau mot de passe imposé par orange
au départ plusieurs appels à l'opérateur
pour une panne de sa livebox
autrement dit de l'internet haut débit
pour l'ordinateur et la télé pour seule
réponse
cette lettre avec ce nouveau mot de
passe à connotation raciste quand on
voit un sale arabe et on revient à la au
moyen âge ça détruit silence embarrassé
de l'opérateur depuis le courrier du 7
décembre puis des excuses dans les
médias aujourd'hui seulement la
direction d'orange se dit indignée elle
cherche l'auteur du mot de passe
hautement controversée en règle générale
nos applications informatiques génère
des identifiants de connexion et des
mots de passe de manière automatique et
aléatoire le fait de trouver ce type de
mots de passe et nous peut être que liés
à une intervention manuelle
l' enquête interne vise donc un éventuel
téléconseillers malveillants
le responsable risque des sanctions
jusqu'au licenciement et peut-être même
des poursuites judiciaires
car la victime a bien l'intention de
porter plainte elles ont l'âge de jouer
à la poupée mais elles sont déjà plongés
dans la vie des concours après les miss
france le concours des miss des mini
miss s'est déroulée le week-end dernier
à les parents sont généralement très
fier mais les psychologues s'interroge
toujours sur le bien fondé de ces
spectacles pour les enfants c'est le
dossier de cette édition
il est signé mallory yao nous jean
francois monier jamais sans sa nouvelle
couronne
le matin avant l'école les après midi de
jeux avec sa soeur elle ne s'en sépare
plus son titre international quatrième
dauphine france 2008 un peu plaisir
quelques années un peu secret et j'adore
défiler la devancer j'adore chanter
en fait j'aime tout un peu traite une
petite star quoi les parents on
t'encourage et ce rêve de petite fille
ils ont inscrit les deux soeurs au
concours de samedi dernier quarante six
fillettes de 7 à 12 ans en lice pour
devenir minimise soirées paillettes pour
cette famille c'était avant tout un
divertissement
on a bien mangé le champagne on a vu
même moi j'ai vu on a ajouté me sont à
ces manifs et cela motive ça lui donne
de l'assurance
elle est fière d'elle on est fier d'elle
on continue et on verra bien apprécié si
ça va plus loin on verra on verra à quel
niveau
car la compétition était bien là surtout
pour les plus rodés les concours
foisonnent sur internet ils sont peu
contrôlée car ne relève pas de la loi
sur le travail des enfants
certains observateurs s'inquiètent cette
course à la célébrité vient depuis 2001
depuis l'émergence de la télé réalité en
france et il c'est vrai que les parents
sont des fois amenés à pousser leurs
enfants à aller sur des scènes des
podiums est telle que les enfants ne
vont pas envie d'y aller
peut-être certes on est loin des excès
américain des filles est transformée en
poupée exhibé comme des trophées
en 1990 la première élection française
de mise de 4 à 8 ans avait déclenché une
polémique avant d'être interdite
elle reprend en 2003 les règles ont
changé fini les maillots l'émission plus
âgés le look le charisme et le talent
ses trois associés qui est qui détermine
la minimise et la mini star donc pas de
concours de beauté pour nous puisque
d'ailleurs il n'ya pas de maquillage
donc aucun artifice
on leur demande d'être habillé classique
mais les familles restent libres de
préparer leur numéro voici la gagnante
marine corse 8 en minimise bardot sur sa
harley
une parodie bon enfant pour certains
mais pour les psychologues c'est grandir
beaucoup trop vite aux petites filles
elles vont pas jouer et vont elles vont
pas jouer à être grand n'allons pas
jouer à lattaquié elle va vouloir
séductrice à un moment donné à leurs
dépens je crois prophète tout est
compliqué pour grandir tranquillement
reste que la réussite de jeunes stars le
rêve d'une célébrité facile continue de
fasciner la meilleure chanteuse de la
soirée enregistrera un album mini-miss
france partira elle à la conquête du
titre européen puis mondial
en bref une image du noël de l'élysée
comme chaque année 600 enfants du
personnel de la présidence était
accueilli aujourd'hui autour du sapin et
pour animer cet après midi il y avait
une ex top model pas forcément celle
qu'on attendait adriana karembeu a
participé à la distribution des cadeaux
avec entre autres vous l'avez aperçu
l'acteur benoît poelvoorde
une rencontre maintenant elle était l'un
des grands espoirs du ski français
sandra laoura médaillée de bronze aux
jeux de turin en 2006 elle vit
aujourd'hui dans un fauteuil roulant
depuis une grave chute lors d'un
entraînement il y a un an
nous l'avons accompagné à la plagne en
savoie c'est une leçon de vie c'est le
dossier de cette édition il est signé
manuel tissier et m'a dit dis ouah dans
la grande famille du sport français
sandra laoura est un peu la petite soeur
préférée cloué sur un fauteuil roulant
depuis un an
la skieuse acrobatique retrouve la
plagne alors pour le soleil la neige et
les souvenirs de sa vie de championne
l'aviez pas rose et pour quiconque est
encore moins pour moi en ce moment mais
j'ai revu d'années j'ai vu un hôtel
d'une station j'ai revu mes amis ben
voilà c'est encore un cap que j'ai
franchie et que je pensais peut-être pas
pouvoir franchir j'ai quand même fait
chier je suis contente et puis ça me
fait du bien
en février 2006 son sourire avait
illuminé le podium des jeux de turin
sandra laoura offre est au ski freestyle
tricolore sa première médaille chez les
femmes
mais un an plus tard à l'entraînement un
saut comme celui ci fait basculer sa vie
elle chute à la réception deux vertèbres
fracturées moelle épinière touché sandra
laoura se bat depuis pour retrouver
l'usagé de ses jambes
oui en deux mois j'ai récupéré mon bac 5
un peu plus de trois mois donc j'ai tout
la mobilité j'ai des sensations
superficiels sont déçus des cuisses sur
le bel effet c'est aujourd'hui sandra
laoura prépare sa reconversion dans la
communication de la piste à l'ordinateur
sans regret ni amertume
j'en veux à personne j'en veux à rien et
c'est peut-être ce qui nous fait ce qui
me fait aller bien peut-être que si j'en
voudrais quelqu'un si j'avais vraiment
la haine ou du des groupes seraient plus
difficiles
j'avancerais platement sandra laoura se
bat pour revivre debout quatre heures de
rééducation par jour derrière ce sourire
la rage de vaincre comme une nouvelle
médaille à conquérir
je pense que dans le sport il ya
certaines émotions qu'on vit qu'à
travers le sport et convient pas
envies d'ailleurs donc c'est émotionnel
j'en ai encore besoin et c'est ce qui me
fait avancer aussi paris sous toutes les
coutures c'est le thème d'une exposition
qui se tient à l'hôtel de ville jusqu'au
31 mars une exposition de photos
l'originalité de ces clichés c'est
qu'ils sont tous en couleurs même ceux
qui date du début du 20e siècle
christophe airaud didier d'armes paris
et ses lumières paris et ses couleurs
chaque jour ce sont des milliers de
clichés paris mitraillé paris
photographié en couleurs depuis un
siècle
oui juste un siècle car c'est un matin
de juin 1907 que léon gimpel pour la
première fois immortalise en couleurs la
capitale
1907 l'année où les frères lumière
invente la plaque autochromes et nous
tellement habitués à l'évocation noir et
blanc de paris découvrons tout à coup
son vrai visage
sa couleur rend les choses sans doute
plus familière plus proche de nous plus
vivante et un petit peu bizarre c'est à
dire il s'est peut-être gauche qui vient
du fait que sans paix de prière et en
même temps on voit de multiples détails
aux vêtements et c'est que ce sont des
images anciennes
la couleur comme documentaire 1930
premier petit film en couleur place de
la concorde
les premiers petits embouteillages la
couleur comme témoin 1941 42 43
andré zucca photographe collabos et
l'occupation nazie si rarement montré à
travers ses couleurs glacial durant tout
le 20e siècle paris a été un formidable
décor pour les hommes d'image mais
aujourd'hui que peut-on encore inventé
dans cette ville
réponse avec stéphane couturier dans
l'exposition il dévoile les chantiers
lavilliers éventré en mutation mais
toujours coloré le côté organique de des
chantiers des transformations urbaines
c'est pour montrer que ce tissu urbain
il est vivant il est en transformation
permanente et que la couleur fait partie
justement de de cette transformation de
la ville les chantiers de stéphane
couturier les horizons tête à l'envers
de philippe ramette ce sont les paris en
couleurs version 21e siècle
et c'est sur la capitale sera toujours
un terrain de jeu ou en couleur pour les
photographes avant de refermer cette
édition je vous en rappelle l'un des
principaux titres
une collision entre un tgv et un camion
s'est produite ce matin dans l'ain un
passage à niveau elle a fait un mort le
chauffeur du poids lourd et une
trentaine de blessés dans la rame
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi que tu te la météo
nathalie rihouet 20h50 le tuteur avec
roland magdane à demain
non
de l'info continue c'est aussi sur
france 2 point fr
tous